le cinéma maintenant cinéma avec
plusieurs films qui sortent ou qui sont
sortis cet été qui ont tous un point
commun c'est que dedans il ya un
comédien qui s'appelle vincent lindon
alors c'est un jeune française c'est le
petit jeune qui monte on peut dire
bonjour vincent lindon
je vous remercie d'être avec nous leur
ferons que ça parfois vous faites une
télé comme ça que j'ai très peur 16
alors habitués vous parce que moi je
suis sûr que vous allez refaire beaucoup
d'autres alors d'abord quelques
précisions au match enfin je sais vous
avez été journaliste un petit peu non
j'ai pas vraiment aux journalistes j'ai
j'ai travaillé au matin de paris où j'ai
déchargé de vendre de l'espace
publicitaire
c'est à dire que je démarchais des
clients et je leur demandais si vous
voulez pour une certaine sommes passés à
l'espace publicitaire dans ma rubrique
qui s'appelait téléphone service au
matin de paris
ou alors c'était pas vraiment
journalisme mais à cette époque là vous
pensiez déjà deux comédiens oui il ya
longtemps que j'ai envie de faire ça
mais j'avais un peu peur de jeter à
l'eau et puis ça se passe toujours comme
ça c'est une coïncidence
un ami qui veut dire comment ça se passe
parce qu'on s'est pas fait dans mon cas
ça s'est passé très simplement un jour
j'avais une après midi devant moi et
j'ai été dans un cours d'art dramatique
pour demander combien ça coûte et de
s'inscrire
et puis comme c'est le prix m'a pas
étonné je me suis inscrit puis une fois
j'étais inscrit j'étais obligée d'y
aller
et puis doucement j'ai pris plaisir à
jouer à faire des petites scènes avec
des amis es
et puis un jour mais comment ça allait
marcher avec nous alors on rencontre
importante c'est pas le boujenah qui est
passé dans les couloirs du court il
cherchait francis huster et il m'a
demandé
il m'a demandé où je pouvais oui pouvez
trouver francis et je vais faire sans
faire exprès comme je suis très
débordant d'enthousiasmé que des cas une
bêtise à faire je la fais tu dis mais
vous êtes paillis ou à qui ça la fait
rire et il m'a il m'a convoquée pour
passer les essais et j'ai des prix pour
le faucon alors ça c'était en 83 renter
en septembre 83 alors depuis ça a été
très vite parce que vous avez fait pas
mal de films et récemment encore alors
proche une prune elle brûle blues pardon
qui est sorti cet été il ya eu vous
étiez dans 37 2 le matin
hélas deux films qui sortent quasiment
en même temps est amusant ce que le
deuxième dont on va parler tout à
l'heure ses idylles connection c'est le
film de paul boujenah un autre film paul
boujenah
donc il est fidèle est alors celui dont
on va parler maintenant ces escort girl
escort-girls un film de bob swaim né un
fils ma production américano anglais si
ça alors c'est quoi escort girl très
vite on va regarder un extrait mais de
quoi c'est l'histoire d'une escort girl
c'est à dire un milieu londonien c'est à
dire c'est une fille
s'ils ont eu peur qui est docteur en
science et pour gagner un peu plus
d'argent
elle s'inscrit dans un organisme
d'escort girls ce sont des filles qui
accompagnent des gens des clients pour
leur tenir compagnie mais qui sont pas
des prostituées elles peuvent si elles
veulent pousser à bout j'ai prolongé
mais c'est pas des prostituées c'est
d'aider des femmes qui sont là pour nos
compagnies qui sont généralement très
belle et il ya ça de plus en plus en
tout cas en angleterre à ce que bob seul
m'a dit alors celle-ci va tenir
compagnie à michael caine et puis bien
sûr une histoire policière là dessus on
envoie un extrait tout de suite
escort girl de bob swaim nous voyons